AS WE GO INTO OUR NEXT GAME, THE
AA-TEAM.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: NOW, YOU KNOW WHEN
YOUR FRIENDS GET DRUNK SOME
DON'T STOP HUGGING YOU AND
OTHERS WANT TO START A FIRE IN
THE PARKING LOT AND FIST FIGHT
EVERY STATE TROOPER AT
FRIENDLY'S?
ACCORDING TO THE
STATE OF MISSOURI UNIVERSITY
THERE ARE FOUR TYPES OF DRUNKS:
THE MARY POPPINS, THE ERNEST
HEMINGWAY, THE NUTTY PROFESSOR
AND THE MR. HYDE.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT
HEMINGWAY AND MR. HYDE KILLED
THEMSELVES AND MARY POPPINS WAS
STABBED IN A PRISON RIOT.
IF YOU KNOW ME I USE TO DRINK
ALL OF THE ALCOHOL IN THE WORLD
WHEN I WAS YOUNGER. AND IF I
RECALL THERE ARE ACTUALLY
MORE THAN FOUR KINDS OF DRUNKS.
I WAS THE STAY DRUNK MARSHMALLOW
MAN.
THAT'S ME.
>> YOU'RE DRUNK IN THAT PICTURE.
Chris: LOOK AT THAT DOUGHY
FACE FULL OF BOOZE AND SHATTERED
DREAMS.
COMEDIANS, GIVE ME AS MANY OTHER
TYPES OF DRUNKS AS YOU CAN.
>> THE HUG-A-COP GUY.
>> THE VICE PRESIDENT.
Chris: POINTS.
ALICE.
>> THE RECENT BLOOD DONOR.
Chris: POINTS.
ALICE AGAIN.
>> OKAY.
SANTA.
>> Chris: POINTS.
RANDALL.
>> THE I JUST WALKED IN ON MY
PARENTS HAVING SEX.
>> Chris: HARI.
>> THE KEITH RICHARDS.
Chris: RANDALL.
>> THE MY PARENTS WALKED IN ON
ME HAVING SEX.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ALICE.
>> THE GIRL WHO THINKS SHE CAN
SPEAK SPANISH.
>> Chris: RANDALL.
>> THE I JUST HAD SEX WITH MY
PARENTS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ALICE.
>> THE OVERLY CONFIDENT
FREESTYLE RAPPER.
>> Chris: HARI.
>> BILLY RAY CYRUS AFTER HE SAW
THE "WRECKING BALL" VIDEO.
>> Chris: POINTS.